[Music]
hello everybody welcome to another game
spot livestream I'm John Luke and I'm
joined by Matt hello and we are playing
and get it there it is Mike wish Jake
wish is what we're playing yeah oh he
says it right when you when you load up
the game yeah yeah thank wish totally
and like typical the way I kind of saw
it with that is like almost like she
would call me ray or you know resonate
believe all did evil I love games I do
about it
yeah yeah no name boldly this is
vanquish on the PC oh yeah just came out
today he said we can uh why don't we hop
right into this game sure so showing it
off let's do it
yeah the games available today for like
he's twenty twenty dollars
yes about twenty bucks unless you bought
Bayonetta and then you can get it for
about like twenty five percent off
something like that yeah yeah I want you
got a mission here okay yeah and we're
gonna show off from the first act eight
deck one at one okay and then right here
yeah that's a good part giant okay so uh
this game is by the way I'm going to be
looking at the chat so if you guys have
any questions let us know
this game came out about seven years ago
and is it is and it's I think it totally
holds up I forgot to get that yeah yeah
get those little secrets at you said
alright so yeah this game I think
completely holds up partly because no
one's really like copied this game Oh in
the the seven years since has come out
Wow
well okay whatever but anyway yeah yeah
totally uh this game really is sort of
one of a kind in terms of its like terms
of mechanics yeah a lot of games that
play like it
absolutely no I I did a I did a feature
about why this game so cool that went up
this morning over on youtube.com slash
GameSpot go check it out check it out
it's definitely a good feature about why
Vince is so legit but one of the things
I mentioned was how uh kind of like when
this game came out a lot of shooters and
in general were very slow and this game
was like way faster pace than any of
those games and um only now are we
getting games like like titanfall 2 and
doom that are like much much faster and
more about like speed and mobility and
precision and I feel like Vanquish kind
of like fits right at home with those
and it kind of like sort of thinking
about just like I like this game uh it's
kind of ahead of its time in a lot of
ways hmm sorry I scheme demands a
certain kind of focus oh yeah no that's
fine let you you focus on the game I'll
just I'll just stop do that it's totally
fine I'll try it chime in whenever
possible oh oh sure that's what I wanted
to do that works too
all right Sarah playing on the the PC
version we're playing at max settings
here it is running at a very very smooth
frame rates so the game is unlocked
unlocked framerate so this is definitely
60 plus I can't tell you the exact
amount of frames this is running because
um normally the way I do it is through
shadow play has an option to check your
framerate but whenever I try doing it
through this game it does not pop up so
I'm actually not sure exactly how many
frames were getting but it is a leagues
above the original 30 max you would get
on the consoles I feel like this game
like the the unlock framerate has oh oh
no has a to his in turn unlocked the
true potential of this game totally
totally it definitely moves much more
like the sort of action game
that it's sort of taking from you I mean
like yes when you see like a game like
Bayonetta isn't bad or or even like more
recently like near those games always
seem to move it's like sixty right and I
imagine that was probably their original
vision yeah totally totally
it's crazy going back because like I was
playing a little bit the ps3 version
like a this week and it's weird seeing
this game now it's so running so yeah i
running so smoothly yeah it was a
digital foundry has a really good
comparison videos they put out I was
watching that I was just like oh wow
yeah
I forgot how choppy it can look lying it
at there's always fire Becker wants to
know what is this game about narrative
wise this game is Rio and tell John Luke
tell them real campy
so the premise is like a Russian coup
has a stolen the so where we are right
now is like this colony this um there's
like giant like floating Space Station
colony and if they have this giant like
superheated I guess it's just their
energy source like they get the solar
energy from the Sun and the Russians
have like taking over the station and
using that solar energy to launch a
giant weapon that is frying America
cities so the military has been sent in
to try and stop them and you are Sam
Gideon this DARPA agent with this insane
augmented suit that allows you to but
slide and go into slow-mo and honestly
like that's kind of the premise of the
game it's pretty light on story for the
most part like but there's a lot of
cutscenes a lot of like cool action
moments happening I kind of a kin it to
like an 80s action movie where it's like
okay you got the like ridiculous premise
upfront and then it's sort of just there
to excuse all the insane action in set
pieces of
that happened throughout the rest of the
game you got these gravelly voiced
heroes yeah he's in charge yeah what
we'll get some dialogue later Sam
Gideon's like this kind of want to be
Solid Snake he's constantly smoking a
cigarette actually the first time I
heard him I thought he was actually
voiced by David Hayter because he sounds
a lot like him but it's totally not some
got the guys name interestingly enough
its voice but if anyone who out there
has played final fantasy 12 he's voiced
by the actor who does what is his name
Alfieri okay gentlemen fella just kind
of a weird shift J uh in terms of like
delivery totally and then burns is a
voiced by good old Steve Blum who always
turns in a good gravelly performance can
do no wrong in that way I think my um
there is a good period of the in the
mid-2000s where every every video game
like guard enemy would be voiced by
either Steve Blum or John DiMaggio yeah
yeah and I would get like really excited
when I play like Riddick or something
like oh there's Steve um John as you
having a conversation before I kill them
there's always funny like noticing
especially Steve Bloom's noticing how
often appeared and stuff yes like
realistic and uh what's the other guy
the guy who from the guy voice is Prince
of Persia Oh
Yuri Yuri Lowenthal yeah yeah everything
yeah yes true what a lot of anime stuff
I think the moment that I really like I
really caught me that like lousy looms
and a lot of things when I think I heard
him voice a 7/11 commercial on the radio
really yeah like that is that spike
Spiegel totally sounds like um uh all
right let's get something I think just a
voice in um
could be wrong Steve plumber maybe
someone else somebody else what's up
with these screen tearing gsync settings
there are vsync settings I'm not seeing
screen tearing on our end yeah so that
might be something about the way it's
outputting I do want to pause for a
second see if we could go to the options
here options so go down all the way to
the graphics cool see keep going it
should be at the very bottom these why
we turn that on see if that helps out
there okay stream there okay chase get
me some other settings yes sir right
hopefully that'll help up will make
things too jarring and weird looking uh
so he says turn off vsync hello okay
well we'll try vsync gone we'll see if
that helps Tamar in the chat uh doing
his steve blum you got to get out of
here fool oh no I feel like I have to
speaking of gravelly voice as it plays
oh oh no I was one thing I always
practice when I was a kid trying to Don
Solid Snake impression yeah yeah cuz I
was obsessed with him yes we uh we would
always do me my brother would always do
your friend tell than that okay there
was a period where my brother would
always just turn to me and go do you
like my sunglasses brother we're just
going to the brother
totally could you pass the salt brother
let's come in doing weighted towards
that Abed pops in I think up a new steep
one boys posture out thanks to more oh
man
my favorite quote is coming up pretty
soon in this game
everything's I memorized
giant robots coming from the ground
looking good good situation
there here it is immense oh there might
be a citation
oh no it's like that you still talk to
him yeah that's weird
I remember him talking but anyway that's
my favorite quote time to hit hard and
make him regret it anyway that's a good
solid snake you got going back good
David Hayter got that gravel down you
can just don't even let me start on them
man I tell you they're like quotes I
know if in that game you're pretty good
um Dan yeah yeah sure like him exactly
what it is
there's something about that it's all
about graveling it up at the end of a
sentence while doing like a kind of map
heightened like hello what's going on
and then like there's a certain like he
extends letters like for a certain
amount time the words totally hello yeah
hello
wow I'm impressed that is really good
well thank you I've been honing it for
years for years and I think of my
favorite quote which was like during
mgs3 well obviously well there's so many
good lines from yeah trying it a
technique you only heard about the
middle battle wasn't very smart you're
asking to have a gun jab on you besides
you're not cut out for an automatic
anyway you tend to pull back your arm do
it okay I'm not gonna go yeah there's
another hole oh yes I love it okay let's
focus let's do some killing of this
Argus core robot felony wait oh god it's
such a video gaming thing that I a lot
of people hate it but I just I don't
know maybe it's because I just love
cheesy stuff but I love um voice actors
didn't really gravelly voices to sound
badass in video game it's totally it's
fun like yeah I'm reminds you've all
like that you know that's like a movie
like star characters they had like no
like action movie so yeah like yeah I'm
kind of in a minority but I love the
voice of Geralt from The Witcher gosh
and I know like so many people like I
hate him I hate his voice it just it's
so gravely and
Oh sounds like he's chewing rocks and I
love it I love his voice nothing wrong
with chewing rocks man its
transformation to a robot you know oh my
love about this game so over-the-top the
fact that I'm doing this right now
yeah I mean really um he's like the
third third mission yeah these missions
goodbye real quick - um I feel like at
most like a mission will last you like
15 minutes each if that right yeah
they're very they go by pretty quickly
somebody wants to know who had more
influence on this release Sega or
platinum
I assume say go yeah I imagine from our
mech library yeah this isn't necessarily
a platinum deal although I'm sure they
had no issues with wanting to get this
game It's Made remembering master the
fact that like platinum had a deal with
Sega that was a lot of good lot of their
first games came out published by Sega I
mean they oh so it was it was crazy me
there's a recent I would sound the
QuickTime events a little weird just
because I could never tell if I did it
right right it's like am i spinning is
it really wicked yeah like mine doing
that not a were yes first out of their
fellow alright there was an article
recently where they were talking about
how the it was platinum has their first
ever original IP that they own right
first time and I had this moment of like
are you guys talking about like fine I'm
stunned a ton of original games like
they meta and vanquish but specifically
they've never owned it ourselves
like yeah like the you know Sega owns
Bayonetta and vanquish and
like wonderful 101 I think is owned by
like Nintendo and stuff like that right
there's all these games that they've
done that are like you know I think
Platinum's been pretty good about
balancing their license games with
original games but that's interesting
that like they now own a thing that they
called 100% bears yeah I'm totally
excited for whatever that turns out to
be too you know yeah cool I'm sure they
won't want to make that too a thing can
I shoot out your good aid oh okay that
didn't really work out for anything but
that was cool that I could do that the
the other thing people forget about this
game is it was directed by Shinji Mikami
yeah yeah we did Oh Resident Evil 4 this
was shortly after he left Capcom he kind
of like paired up with this is when he
was still with platinum technically yes
it was under their employment before he
left do like evil within and stuff right
and I was looking up some stuff about
him and according to Wikipedia he said
that evil within was the last game he
was planning on directing oh yeah that's
true that's true I mean he still likes
games but I think it's more of a
producer capacity right not as much like
fully directing them which is
interesting because there's been all
sorts of rumors about evil within -
right totally I mean you could just not
be directing that I see yeah I mean I'd
uh be curious
I'd never finished evil with him me
neither I liked it I enjoyed it as the
fact of like you know being kind of like
a Resident Evil 4
kind of yeah ish game I got right she
was I kept getting frustrated with it I
would get stuck in areas where I hadn't
liked no ammo oh yeah and I had to like
I'd have to like go back a bunch of
times and I was just like I don't know
if I'm just playing this wrong or
something but I was just getting really
frustrated with it and like literally
get to like load back like checkpoints
in order to like try to come on
or like a previous like areas be like
well okay I have like
no ammo right right for a game that is
like so like it's still like for as much
as they said it was gonna be like really
traditional travel or like it still
plays very much like an action horror
game yes yeah that's the other thing and
I think the thing that's the problem is
that does really follow suit in terms
the resources it provides you that's for
sure
yeah beautifully because I would
specifically be an area where I had to
fight Rozier
right James Caan well uh Cornwell says I
didn't realize this game was so loved by
people yeah that's the thing is a lot of
people just like don't really like
remember that rabbit this game right so
a lot of people tweeted at me after I
put out my video this morning or saying
like wow like I'd no idea like people
loved this game so much or like I've
never heard of it this looks awesome I'm
gonna go check it out and like that's so
awesome because that is exactly why I
made that video was like hey this game's
rad and it deserves a second chance
you may not know what this game is or
why people like it so much here you go
so that warms my heart
yeah totally it's great to hear that
because this you know when I it is kind
of like you when you do look back at
like when this game first came out yeah
I liked there no one really bought it
like I feel like I was the only one at
the game stuff that I was at that
pre-ordered it back in the day right um
which is unfortunate and I tried to get
my friends into it get them to try the
demo but I don't think they could really
see through what it was trying to do at
the time
it kind of just I was like I was Jan
Erik and shooter or they just like I
mean I mean victory for the game doesn't
it kind of does it to itself a little
bit it's a very new color palette in a
lot of spots it I think at first glance
it's sort of like okay excuse of war but
you can like but slide and you kind of
think that's all there is to it but you
don't realize like how sort of insane
how much get there is to like the
different mechanics
skills to it totally totally surprising
amount of depth to it like that if
anything actually like if you play this
game you may not see it when you're
playing the campaign but like I think
the place where that all the mechanics
were really truly standout is when you
do like the challenge by the rice stuff
if we're going to try check out a little
bit yeah yeah sure I mean yeah you get
that something is you can actually go
through this game the game has a good
enough of a difficulty curve that
playing it on normal you can get through
it on its own
doing you know a couple of mechanics but
not really like going crazy in depth
with them or utilizing every system and
still having like a pretty fun time
which is um there's a really great video
that actually talks about how like
that's like a really just that's
something that platinum intentionally
does with their games they always talk
about how they make their games to be
accessible for the lowest tier of person
and then go like up from there right
right and I'd say that like that this is
that type of game it's like you can just
play this game
do a couple the cool you know like rolls
in and a our south and butt slides and
have a decent time but like when you get
to like you know the the god difficulty
oh god hard that is uh which is a
reference to them Mikami's previous game
right god hand got hand
that's that's when the game really uh
really ramped up yeah really demands
your mastery of its mechanics and it's
funny it almost challenges you because
like the whole thing is it reduces the
amount of boost you have because as you
see you like when you're using it at
dwindles right doing this on even faster
in that difficulty mode right now and
almost in a way challenges you to play
vanquish like a third person shooter
with no like slow motion right abilities
which is actually very hard you really
do like your ability to slow down time
is absolutely pivotal to survival in
this game but yet to like to have that
be like hindered and limited does really
like change up the game whole lot yeah
OOP my cylinder so I mentioned
Bulletstorm in the chat yeah bold storms
also I'd say another game that that
almost like a subtle like in spirit
influence its error like almost subtly
influence by Baker's you know HP's okay
that was one of the games like when I
cuz after a finished vanquish I was like
what do I play now that like gets that
feeling you know like polo storms kind
of a performer has some of that because
in fact of how like rkt it is and also
the fact that did have like a slide and
it's got a slide you can kick into
people yeah huh yeah thought together
that's a good and that game also didn't
really sell very well when it came out
either no it didn't I mean they that we
released actually recently got a
remastered but yeah although I think
they kind of messed up on that one where
this one they're like hey we're putting
it on PC twenty bucks
right right that one they were like
charging full 60 bucks for that alright
and I was like I love Bulletstorm a I'd
say bolt storm is in the same realm of
vanquish that's like oh man underrated
game more people should play it I love
it fast-paced in its own sort of toilet
but when they were like hey you want to
pay 60 bucks for I was like
that's all they do keeping mode sells it
for me you know apparently I do new
commode was only if you pre-ordered it
Oh what you'd have to pay an extra five
bucks on top of that I know like that's
the thing I feel like they really messed
that one up
I was like oh like I was like don't do
that game deserves a better like don't
screw that up
right anyway my rant about a monster
movie master good game though yeah you
can get that remaster like on the cheap
like I mean please do like that game
deserves all the love I can get same
with this game yeah yeah totally
just think thinking about okay I'm just
kind of reminded that like the time for
a bet you know where I was at was when I
was playing the first time I've been
after playing it and like yeah I mean
bolt storm was the game that like I kind
of went to being like like I guess this
is good enough alternative at this point
like it is similar enough but like I
just just the fact that I kind of had to
go through that trip of like what my
fine it's like vanquish right you're not
really being able to find anything like
yeah so slow back then
exactly boy people are mentioning a
Binary Domain
who binaries in a domain is actually for
you I know it's minor domain is a very
good game heavily underrated shooters
well it kind of fits in the same mold of
this game where it's uh just like at
first glance there like I was kind of
like a generic third-person shooter but
I can spend like a lot of heart to it
yeah it's pretty nice I mean sweep of
the Yaak is it guys yeah like its story
and narrative is like really engaging
and we don't expect yeah and it's a like
I mean is shooting is confident although
it's got that really ridiculous um fully
voiced you can play the game fully blow
boys come out right it's not that great
yeah really fun totally totally and yet
your your your homie big bow
big bow hokey boom big vote yeah big
though is best there's that robot who
was French man I games great I should
wear yeah totally it exists within the
sphere like the games that are sort of
underappreciated underappreciated
Japanese games
yeah there's a lot of games that came
out in the late 2000s in Japan that I
think are totally totally as must be
we're just so quick to write it off and
I think it was during a time where a lot
of Japanese developers were not Castro
no they were struggling yeah they were
Caidic try it like they're kidding to
trends trying to figure out how to sort
of survive or try that which is why you
could argue I think people looked at
this and they're like oh it's just like
Japanese people trying to cater to
Western use award right right but in
reality they more it feels like they
took that concept and then like rolled
with it yeah totally rather than just
copied it I remember there were people
like I'm rereading old comments saying
like what that what is this like a weird
Japanese masterchief I'm just like oh my
god no dude like come on it was that
intensely really like people kind of
felt like oh the Japanese game sort of
had lost their identity in that way and
they're just in college teaching other
one else we try to like try to be like a
you know a triple that Triple A
third-person shooter but totally fail at
that kind of thing
absolutely I like this comment so once
the Sam from vanquished series is more
faster than Sonic dang right he is oh my
gosh they should race they're both
psychic characters they can do he could
do that a crossover Sega make it happen
uh yeah uh
SoCal Odom on says speaking of Yakuza
there's a franchise that should
definitely be on PC absol oh my gosh
Jacques would be amazing yeah I'd like
to have that entire library okay so
serious so long deal like what do you
thinking about it they have said we want
to take more franchises and put them on
the PC they have vivid Sega has stayed
in that's the next step man right that's
the next step not exactly we know it now
first here everybody guys you heard it
here definitely 100% coming to PC we can
confirm and but I want it oh geez I mean
already have them all on the consoles
but I think I've actually never played
any of the ocular games I know
John Luke I'm actually only like a
recent convert but you know dude yeah
well every time I say that everyone is
shocked because you're a gentleman do
you love like kind of like weird niche
Japanese games and you play like persona
which is like a already like kind of
there
like the social sim elements don't do
you love this game um what I know I
would I just never had the chance
Oh y'all kisses zero is a perfect place
just good is a good place to start over
there yeah but then the problem is I'm
like well I kind of want to play all of
them yeah totally right to go back would
be really tricky so I need like I need
just just that collection right yeah you
need well I mean you was so jock is a
zero is out and they're going to come
out with the remake of yoga sub 1 on
PlayStation 4 at the end of the year so
then maybe you got some time before they
might release the opposite to him three
and four and five and then eventually
six or not realize six doesn't come out
game but anyway
I think we should still keep we get we
do one more yeah okay
close the door that mentioned Joey knows
I'm not sure what he's referring to I
missed that
Liz James says John we didn't finish his
homework again never allowed to play
only allowed to host no I uh I let uh I
went Matt play this one for the stream
because he is way better at this game
than I am
Oh what you were doing pretty good man
I'm bad but watching you play I was like
oh he's better
oh he's bad at this Kim and I on he
should he should do the string I mean
you do I do want to say that you do you
know I mean you at least know about the
Debus cancel which is a thing I do know
about the news cancel and another thing
Billy people it takes you because the
game doesn't explain it
Yeah right the the melee is different
depending on which weapon you're holding
right totally and you can actually like
use that like I'm the heavy assault
rifle for example yeah pistola you can
do that do a back flip and then kit and
then go into AR mode which you can't do
with the other weapons totally so kind
of almost and that's such a useful
ability that it you almost always want
to have one of those weapons on you
so man couldn't do that I mean even this
here too like this a strategic option to
like if because the motor using melee
you your boost basically has to be
charged right but when you have a disc
launcher it just your booster doesn't
need to be charged which it uses up a
piece of ammo on the disc launcher which
I'll probably show cases yeah I like
those on a robot couple people there you
go and you can kick that cover up too as
well oh yeah that's right oh I don't
have the you don't have the thing
anymore he switched ok I'm going back
and doing oh let's do it oh please be
still still be there oh no oh he's
leaving
come back here spider cover robot wow
they're just somebody random rebuilding
you're ruined says hey John look at Matt
are there any other PlatinumGames who
want to see come to PC oh boy
games on PC um what else is there left
what hasn't hasn't come out to PC it uh
well there's definitely the mad world
game or mad world hasn't come out on
Visa right that's um that's a Nintendo
partnership fair right is it I thought
Sega put that out I know it was on the
wii obviously but I don't know maybe I
wonder who if they Nintendo kind of has
exclusive rights on the base may come
Anarchy Reigns which is like a kind oh
yeah that was a little equal oh you know
what that would be perfect because
that's an online melee game that never
was able to get a life here because of
the fact that like that was on PC there
it was not on PC No yeah oh my gosh that
would be perfect because like that was a
really fun game but I never really got
the opportunity to play with other
people because the way it worked was
that is like a competitive multiplayer
like brawler kind of like I guess like
you would I guess a similar thing would
be like you know like fur on it right
and the idea of like right right like
fighting dudes that would be great to
have on PC to get int that to have like
a you know they're sort of you know get
I could get that get that to have a
community the community that I deserved
honestly yeah um Bayonetta 2 so this is
Bayonetta 2 that one's a little bit
trickier because it's also uh yeah that
one's definitely Nintendo but it said to
antagonize Nintendo yeah because today I
still owns the name but like they didn't
want to publish it right at this point
I'd be happy with Bayonetta 1 and 2 on
the switch yeah with myself that's what
I would like to um because I at least
until I haven't actually played the PC
version of Bayonetta yet but I heard it
runs pretty well been was like dr.
Bradley yeah I know people were really
positive on it but um the longest time
the the Wii version of a another one
actually was in my opinion the best
version yeah this ring 316 especially
the ps3 version had some ping bugs and
just cleaning the props and stuff right
that was I I'd have an Xbox inside so
that was when I tried right I played the
Xbox one it was really good but I
remember hearing him the ps3 version had
some issues yeah yeah mostly load time
stuff was really right and they just
didn't look as good that was the problem
- who's really washed out by comparison
don't know what kind of went on there I
know the piously was sort of infamous
for being really hard to like make stuff
on right but know that bad you know it's
actually a weird
the one issue I've heard about the PC
version of Bayonetta is the load times
are so fast you actually don't have time
to practice during the loading screens
oh really yeah um there because that was
like such a cool mechanic afoot Oh while
the loading screens happening you can
you can practice right right it goes by
it loads so quick you don't even have
time to practice at all which version
this is not a PC Pro well yeah Bayonetta
I mean you don't look at the load times
for this you'll do the low temperature
this don't have any time to read like
the the flavor text nothing um that's
that's why I like if you're gonna have a
load time that has like a flavor text or
like a mini game light a practice mode
in it you should have a button that says
like press to keep it right right
totally
yeah uh I mean Bayonetta 2 when I got it
I think it was like you could buy it
individually or if you you could get it
with me another one so I got it like
both of them together yeah yeah playing
though I like played in both
back-to-back and man really really good
definitely want that on the switch yeah
that'd be great I mean he can't afford
some more games on there swear yeah
wonderful 101 I have not played that one
but my brother absolutely loved that
game grenade action here I come oh he's
alright
you ever play a wonderful 101 uh me uh
only a little actually owned it I Stefan
really gun yeah I haven't really sat
down I was meant to it to fly it mind my
brother loved it and he was always
trying to get me to play it have like
that cool like kind of super sentai
Harry going on holy oh yeah uh Little
Joe
also was kind of the same thing yeah it
was totally not it's not a platinum game
but it is technically kluever
technically a Planet X platinum I mean
I mean people work to platinum used to
record clover okay so they worked on
that wonderful anything made by clover I
consider technically yeah don't call me
Oh
Okami love that I want to play actually
gotta beat that game so many games along
I've uh so technically this bums me out
the ps3 version of Okami
which is the HDD yeah yeah update they
technically did we did all those
textures in 4k
did they hmm really so I came the game
doesn't run in 4k resolution or anything
but all of the textures in that game are
4k textures so who could totally port
that game to the PC they could put it on
the ps4 Pro I'm like like I know I don't
know I mean like that seems to be on the
lowest of the totem poles for like
Capcom at this point I know well this
guy Capcom show us some some some love
for your older stuff
yeah well commie love like I'm down to
place you fire to again but I want okami
right Peterson playing that yeah yeah
like I'm about tomorrow Wow Oh know what
I think I know is guy think yes if you
come out this week just forget what I
love that you not love this yes great
he's brushing robots Assad says his game
should have been longer um I can
understand why full price $60 you could
maybe disappointed I'm it's pretty short
campaign by them I think the campaign
actually has like a good length to
really I by the end I felt it felt good
right right it doesn't it doesn't like
overstay its welcome that's for sure and
you can breeze through it but I think
what makes Bank we're so great too is
also the fact that like you there is an
initiative never go back at especially
few want to get give the game and play
way that like you know really take
advantage of all the mechanics that was
the thing that really hinged it for me
that made it worse the sixtieth time but
like now 420 that's steel steel for
going to I think it's a total still 420
and because the levels are so short I
think it just adds to its so easy to
want to go back here I'll just go bit
play level right right I mean you're
encouraged to play it as fast as
possible and to get as many points
Clause because it does have that arcade
sort of rkt layer to it you know that
score system on the right right yeah
someone says how did they not make a
huge deal about 4k textures on ps3 even
if the game itself wasn't that
resolution Oh from offer fro commie
um I don't know cuz cuz technically it
mean it wouldn't be rendering it 4k so
it wouldn't matter you wouldn't see
those for cake textures right I don't
even know why they did it like that
right you know I mean I guess it's this
idea that you know you kind of designed
up and then you try to like scale down
from there right I guess I don't really
I don't really know I'm not really sure
how that happened but it was a little
forward-thinking on there and I guess
yeah sector that mess you came in a walk
look oh it did and that's why I'm just
like please put that on ps4 just put it
on our system yes I have right now
yeah oh man go I'm not you're terrific
god the dialogue good it's so self-aware
and it's fun pretty it's pretty nowhere
yeah that's also what made it stand out
too like you know these these
self-serious shooters back in the day
they didn't have time for this kind of
stuff it's kind of like craziness so I
mean like this games just contrast so
well especially during the games at that
time sexy frog live says this game kind
of looks like a faster paced Mass Effect
that's interesting thinking about like
Andromeda and the way that games paced
oh right
being a third-person shooter but having
like that faster speed it kind of you
know in a weird way it does rotate some
cues from Bank which I don't know if
that they intentionally were taking cues
from vanquish but it certainly takes
increases its speed although again not
nearly to the degree or vanquish all
right I start with ink of a cover based
shooter that goes quite as fast as this
slowly I want there to be very like
dominant like I mean really like fully
defined John there shooters that is just
fast but back just like really fast
paced in terms of this kind of like
turns mechanically because if I'm you
could play any shooter bad well again I
feel like we're starting to get there
like titanfall 2 is a great example of a
that was one of the reasons why that was
my one of my favorite games last year is
because it scratches a niche and maybe
one night when I was playing that game
was like it's just like vanquish yeah it
has that that mobility to it that
reminds you a lot of vanquish totally
dad more games like that
are we doing on time somebody says do
you think Platinum's next unannounced
game will be at e3 um well as far as
that one that they just announced their
new IP I don't know because I don't know
how long they've been working on that
yeah
don't know if that article said if that
could be a case of the just they just
started working on it so I don't know if
that's on there what did they have them
in the pipeline
I know well they also said that they're
maybe gonna platinum for a while has had
a pretty steady like a gaming year
release you know between all their
franchise stuff and their their original
stuff and they kind of said that that
might be slowing down a little bit
which I'd be okay with because I
honestly think they should slow down
because I think that's kind of a victim
a little bit alright so I don't know we
might not see anything for them for the
rest of the year I mean they already put
out in here this year so that might be
it
which by the way nears great let me
check it out yeah Nitin ears good oh
okay
the original near came out at the same
time as a vanquish and I also did that
underrated although I would say um near
the original near is like arguably not
actually a good game right um it has a
lot of good stuff in it but it's it's
not really like a polished look gained
in a lot of ways vanquish totally is
ident Lancashire I guess a great game
throughout I agree alright so let's try
for tactical challenge six guys
nightmares for life ninja mu tactical
challenge six that was hell I don't
think we have ours I remember yeah we
don't I don't think we unlocked on the
ass I don't actually it on this yet so
we don't have all the challenges
unlocked
all right do you think we should jump
into challenges or sure you keep just
kind of going in Oh what are we at here
um yeah let's jump into a challenge cool
all right
title screen one thing that um bummed me
out is I had to go back to a previous
save and it rewire all of your weapon
upgrades one is seat so unless you play
the game straight through I went back
and so now I'm like we'll have to do the
game without any my weapon upgrade
someone rocks
oh god which challenge should we do ooh
uh let's start with the first one all
right vanquish feel like that like
saying that it's good time to time
great time all right the guys spawn over
here so let's take care of them I can
get this timing just right before they
start like gunning me down okay oh hi
yeah there we go I think it's doing I do
it three times really run down with my
grenades actually this may not be smart
given like the waves of people but it's
quick quick and easy all right hello big
guy okay
Ricky Williams wants to know we're
rebound about scalebound getting dropped
yes yeah I wanted to see more of what
that would have been the potential what
that could have been yeah I mean I'm the
kind of person who is always willing to
try wladim game I don't love every
platinum game specifically they're
licensed games I oh yeah well I will
never forgive them for for Legend of
Korra uh oh no that was like the first
like what's the first lunder that's real
and then I was like the biggest one that
I was like oh no oh no platinum why do I
have to do that right especially because
I love avatar last airbender and legend
of korra and like thinking about the
universe of those shows I'm like man
these are like just ideal for video
games right like you could make a really
cool video game with like airbending
power all the different like powers and
stuff and the martial arts wow there's a
really cool video game in here somewhere
right finding out like hey platinum is
making a legend of core game you know
Platinum I'm like whoa like the
Bayonetta people are making a core game
that's a match made in heaven this is
gonna be perfect and it was like so
half-assed it was yeah I was bull real
bomb it just did not I mean I'm sure
that game deserves a larger scope I
guess is the whole thing oh jeez no
that's the thing is it feels like they
were given such a restricted because it
was an Activision licensed game it
reminds me of like Activision licensed
games like the spider-man games where
you're like man deep down there's
something good here but like you know it
just feels like didn't have enough time
to work on it right yeah totally so it
Drive or something and I don't know just
I'm not really sure what happened but it
just didn't really work out uh Ben and
the YouTube chat says the the Ninja
Turtles game broke his heart
oh I watched Joey like that oh and I was
like if that looks wrong leaves a little
bit to be desired
yep oh boy
should respond here's your been on the
other side boy a snake does say
transformers devastation was amazing yes
that it's true like so that just the
thing is is it's not like all of the the
license game for bad like they actually
did a really good job with some of their
transformers ones yeah the the turtles
in the coral one nope do you guys like
their will rerelease vanquish in
bayonetta on ps4 Xbox one maybe this is
not a good situation uh they might I
don't know now I would I don't see you
if they can put the resources to it I
think they would especially because you
can then have a console version of like
thankless running at like 60 frames a
second oh yeah okay what they'll do
hey you friend Oh No
yeah okay Power Rangers game made me sad
was there Power Rangers game name a
platinum know if there was was her are
we starting about bad licensed games
though yeah weird about good be talking
about disappointing licensed games there
was plenty of those oh yeah
what about good licensed games oh no
come on alright I can I would have done
now so let's do us I think my favorite
licensed game is a Renick ski from put
oh boy star reader whatever they were at
the time yep they were uh I believe
there's still star breeze though service
okay yeah that games uh amazing oh man
and it looked so good it was on the
original Xbox I looked amazing
yeah like I really like this something
you have a spherical idea like a light
again yeah really really good oh boy did
not take it oh man I'm beefing it I have
a soft spot for um yeah a couple old
star breeds games the original darkness
Oh is actually one of my favorites and
that one does not that's also not on PC
that bums me out really none of them are
on PC not even a second the second one
is so the second one is the second one
was not made by Starbreeze that's really
by different dads I actually like the
second one the second one is totally um
like a good game but there's something
about the first one that's so like weird
and different in the way it it presents
itself that I don't know I just love
that game totally and I really would
really wish I had a proper proper PC
port at some point right it's one of the
few come like I mean one that earlier
comic book games actually cannot be
pretty darn good yeah before uh Kelly
before Batman right yeah I proved you
like oh I you can make a good uh comic
book game right right
what lo you did I think it also helps
that darkness was like so obscure of a
comic book that we must we don't even
know is the comic book dad that's true
it's very much day this is like Topcon i
don't know we it's one of those weird
comic books that came out during like
the 90's or so right i actually read
some of the comic it's like super weird
yeah it is dark that sounds like the
nineties creator-owned comics yup of
that era hmm
dark and weird very square jaws on most
myth male characters do you remember
that it's the age of Gimli okay Oh
yes miss Liz James says you guys have a
great audio setup thank you well I like
these mics we have you feel very
professional when you talk into them
yeah yeah you almost feel like wanting
to talk like like this you know already
getting get that Betsy I think you have
a good radio voice do I I think so yeah
guess I've been told that a couple times
but I'm like oh no I just uh
well is it uh-huh Alexa always like to
point out oh my god we thought everyone
because I appeared on a podcast want her
podcast airship one time and then
somebody likes sentiment like a like an
email and being like good show by the
way who's that guy the buttery boy ha ha
ha like uh uh first time I heard that
about my voice I guess my girlfriend was
always like I told her about that she's
like she won't let me let me let it go
yeah you know that buttery voice oh boy
I always get a Jesse Eisenberg oh yeah
oh ha ok being bombarded every video I
ever do uh somewhere there's a youtube
comment that comments on how I sound
like Jesse Eisenberg alright which I've
never heard that until I started working
here like no one night no one's ever
calming down yeah that's not a
connection that I had had made now it's
just think it's weird like everyone who
knows me is like never made that
connection at all everyone on YouTube
apparently thinks I sound like that guys
like Josie Eisenberg oh boy I don't even
know what Jesse Eisenberg like so yeah I
can't really like think of it on my head
like not that like nothing I could
purely identify just by the way you
sound at this moment I'm hmm cool good
this game is so like this another thing
that is a big thing is games that it is
like you could take cover but most times
like enemies will surround you pretty
quickly it's actually because like in
the actual score page you are graded for
how long you spend in covered Liz jr.
says ASMR Matt and his buttery voice oh
no no no no not I'm trying not to like
be like a buttery voice person right now
be myself do your snake voice alright
just talk like stick the entire time
okay all right so let's oh man I can't I
can't comment like you're doing this tip
I'm too much I could just recite quotes
um after the ended all right after the
end of the second world I'm out okay
after the end of the Second World War
the world was split into two East it
West this began of conflict notice be
given up known as Cold War something
like that
oh yeah yeah good just read me the
entire opening of a snake eater well
like that's a river two years ago I was
living it and just to write Snake
Plissken
oh man I believe I wanna say was like
recently something could you move like
claiming like his inspiration for snake
had nothing to do with escape from New
York and I'm like that no way that's
mole we're talking about there is all of
that there so gesture well after
watching the movie is sort of more
recently to kind of like see what that
was all about no way just that kind of
typical action hero kind of what I've
been then like just like a cynical
connection here again yeah exactly the
retiree right you know like cynical
retired right right I think I remember
my fair quote from that movie was like
you know the president has been captured
and then the president or something like
that and then like Snake Plissken like
president what what oh man that's a good
don't care man you're so cold Snake
Plissken
yeah ah what again what a great game
great with you yeah yeah angry games
totally totally love the nose
whoo-hoo not and I blow you up midair oh
yeah it's that kind of stuff that I live
for in this game I'm I'm Len the enemy's
like that's the thing like whenever you
play this like special challenge modes
like you have to have that proper
balance where like you can never let the
enemy take advantage of like the
territory it's tough rightly feel like
okay and they're getting quickly
overwhelmed but it's okay
they can make and do Mountain Dew do
okay hello there we go yeah I love doing
that it's like my favorite things like
rolling in front of a dude and he's
being hello shotgun and zelphia really
satisfying okay me this little too close
too close that she's awkward little do
gloves little too close all right
where's the next wave at or zero okay
they're hopeful nation is smooth yeah I
mean the animation this one's really
solid oh dude gotta get yeah get those
guys first yeah hello
oh no just get in there get in there bed
oh yes all right save myself a little
hole time
okay well tight yeah the controls on
those are a little actually maybe she
make it priority you option out talking
mushrooms okay I got him them oh boy
does this game have a ranking system or
a generic score attack system um so it
doesn't have the the letter grades the
way most platinum games - there's no
like a you know BCD F instead it's just
a number and I will say that is the one
weird thing about this game is um no one
fully understands the scoring system and
how it works
like I was watching a video we're like
these guys were talking about how like
no one totally gets how it works they're
like it has something to do with like
time and like number of kills and life
is nothing I don't you don't fully
understand the numbers so the scoring
systems a little weird
totally if i buy platinum standards we
get a shotgun up in this game we rocket
launchers that works so far a lot is a
good choice
proved by many means for his Lakes suite
from a gunny okay wait actually I didn't
know I feel like I should say that given
what happens the last wave of this map I
can't wait for people to post on YouTube
new like videos of like their challenge
runs right yeah that's the thing is uh
those haven't been around for a while
yeah they have not and yet they're
amazing and I really want to see what
people come up with because that it's so
cool to just see somebody like beat this
first challenge in like cause like right
now I'm taking like upwards of like ten
minutes or so but there are people out
there who can clear this in like three
that's insane and just so cool just
seeing like that's where you get to see
like how like players are able to really
like you know utilize the mechanics for
all that they you know they were capable
of and then you know the prostitute
makes you better players you can like
kind of look at that but like yeah right
it's just so cool to see what I mean
there's a lot here in this game then you
wouldn't be able to kind of find out
otherwise in some ways listen until you
like sort of experience and kind of see
what other people are up to okay so oh
yeah so bogies here um he's the first
boss I believe what's the plan of attack
for finding a rocket launcher oh here we
go I also get strategy those fit done oh
boy I can overheat it so quickly I mean
it's gonna connect scooping on me pretty
quick if I don't try to do anything
about it I'll talk about Switch games
then mentioned that me No More Heroes
game right yeah right yeah it'll do that
Oh see there's also mixed bag for me
I'm always willing to try every gaming
mix but they're pretty hit or miss yeah
they are you know that was something I
began to notice a little bit uh when I
started playing more of his games yeah
because I loved killer7
and that game came out I liked the first
time where he rose a lot oh yeah no
we're here well yeah the second one I
liked that first one right right so then
like hello pop chainsaw I wanted to like
but I couldn't really get into yeah
James Gunn was surprisingly a part of
that the guy he directed guardians again
was yes that actually doesn't surprise
me
oh yeah right I guess that makes sense
so many things but really it feels just
like there's like a lack of um like a
Polish like technical polish on some of
his games a guy you almost want I mean
it's such like a it's almost like a
cliche at this point of life well they
should just get platinum to make the
action for their game but it's like Ryan
hey if a suit is just like teamed up
with platinum I bet they can make a
pretty cool game totally totally I mean
there was actually one like because
there something I definitely noticed
that like okay Suda's games aren't that
polished and I remember like was it
shows of the Damned
so Shinji Mikami was a badly involved
that that game didn't turn out to be as
great as I thought it was gonna be so
gameplay wise no shadows The Damned is
uh not that great I love shows of the
Damned yeah that's true is a pretty
ridiculous game and it's fun in its own
it's not necessarily the most fun video
game to play and when you consider its
made by Shinji Mikami like really like
that but man the story of that game is
so weird yeah it is a mad like a dream
team of people a part of it just like
you have oh my gosh hello huh okay uh
you have a sudha on there and then you
have Shinji Mikami and then also the guy
who composed the music for Silent Hill
oh right yeah yeah give it some of that
we're that by the atmospheric bug
oh hey but that game is like a three
different opening menus like it has
multiple a title Oh Chuck Chuck oh
there's Lamar we're like he's just like
Oh to get to hell we have to drive eh
is miles per hour on like the highway oh
yeah that's gray dumb I love it you need
to join and then there's the the all the
stories where you there's like the
children's books I have like the
narrations ever oh yeah yeah they're
like fables but it's also all the bosses
it's so good will I do this
slow motion yeah it is done whoo that's
racing a little bit oh yeah you run into
a lot of roadblocks technically if you
like because like yeah the moment that
you get like overwhelmed by the by like
the amounts of enemies then you start
finding yourself playing a little bit
like a cover shooter and then that's
where you're going to lose that
dominance in the battlefield well we got
through it yeah we're about an hour in
um you want to call here do you want to
do one more uh that was a high note but
I wouldn't mind doing something playing
a little bit more but it's up to up to
us and also the also the check check
they want to see one more yeah let us
know guys if you want to see one more I
think we'll maybe do one more maybe yeah
yeah let's try okay all right return to
challenge green all right
hmm the one that I haven't completed
maybe sure all right
vanquish all right
try to focus on this one
oh whoa sniper forgot about you
oh dang keep forgetting about these
snipers out here this map is a lot of
them and they will basically just tear
you treads don't you wanna say that that
gun for later that's true you have a
good point John Luke mm-hmm that is
smart
all right let's get some of these
snipers out of here
so Callan brings up a good point it's
all been an hour no rush
who's that this is only been an hour oh
yeah it's true do you got you got
eventually uh wrap ups and stuff gotta
set up for a Tekken stream we're doing
tomorrow oh yeah I'm gonna be on that
actually
oh are you we're going to get wrecked by
the professional player I'm sure but
yeah
they'll be fun yeah make sure to tune in
guys so wants to notice is only for the
PC yes so this um this is only they'll
on the PC right now unless you happen to
have a ps3 or 360 can find an old copy
of it there but as far as like ps4 Xbox
one not yet
would be nice if they put it out on them
so yeah yeah especially running at 62
yeah more chance to play vanquish always
a good thing
yeah Sega let's do it also um there is
the mouse the keyboard controls are not
bad the added precision from the mouse
is pretty good but trying to like all
the different jumps and stuff on the
WASD Keys is really weird yeah it takes
some getting used to
that's very sure I'm sure someone will
be able to connect that sure exactly
like son will have that that dexterity
to just like pull that off and be
amazing right I would love to see that
like I would be surprised that the
people who run top on the challenge are
playing mouse and keyboard just because
they have that ability to like that
quickly move of the mouse right right
but yeah we're actually have some
gameplay showing off mouse and keyboard
also running at high resolution over at
like 7 o'clock on YouTube so if you're
interested in seeing what that what that
looks like
yeah that'll be up there
boy when's the next way of coming in I
think I'm missing out okay here I go
Oh snow angle great just stand near the
spawn point that's what I want
oh good I didn't do anything to them
Paul oh no oh ha he get up there Pharaoh
oh it's almost yeah that's not like a
hit or two ready nice okay get ready to
salvage that nice
videogame ninja says vanquish has got to
be one of the hardest games to platinum
slash 100% as far as the trophy goes
yeah I bet ya I can't even imagine
trying to do it on the same be a fun
challenge it would be if I make it real
good at vanquish by the end of it I
think that's that's worth it to me just
trying to it is although it's a I want
to see more games like bankers because
the thing is like you good like
Bayonetta right you can like apply to
other action games right oh yeah you can
apply you go to Street Fighter you can
apply it to you know like injustice to
some degree right all right
vanquish you get really good at vanquish
and there's just more vanquish right
right you don't have another game you
can apply that toolset to so even if
vanquish never got a direct sequel
another game that follows in the vein of
vanquish would be really really fun I
think I would love to see that totally
that is my dream to see another game
like make which I just like basically
just reiterating all make success
exactly like it doesn't have to me may
buy platinum just like hey just make use
vanquishes your inspiration to make
another vanquish like game I love that
totally Jada Watson says holy crap this
is fast yes you bet it is
you're right Sam this will come in handy
because I the shotgun is essential but I
really gotta get an understanding of
those uh spawn points see pad says
thanks for the stream off to play the
game dude enjoy do it oh that's awesome
if you've never played before have a
good time yeah or dole says I just don't
know if another company that isn't
platinum could do this game to do this
system justice that's a yeah I'm not
sure like if I was to have another
studio make a vanquish light game who
would it be no no oh no it's over guys
it's over oh oh won't get one more try
sure if we're all down for it yeah so
cow says the game is incredible some of
the things are able to do are hard to
explain like how do you slide into a
crate full of barrels backflip off of it
and shoot the barrels is that it oh you
asking yeah well he was asking how you
do that uh so if you just melee was they
like doing like doing a dash like this
and then you just nailing into a cover
then you can kick off by like once you
kick off just hold the aim button and
then it'll slow down time like that you
could do the same thing to an enemy but
the moment you do to an enemy you lose
all your boost gauge so that's the great
thing about doing that technically is
that when you kick off from cover your
boost doesn't have to recover from zero
yeah it'd be far this game is like that
boost management yeah yeah you always
keep an eye on it I'm not doing that
right now well actually I just got hurt
yeah that's like getting hurt like socks
because on the one hand it's like oh it
gives me the AR to get yourself out of
the situation but on the other hand it
means you've wasted the Bruce's being
it's just it's wasted at that point
which sucks
totally OOP
is it
Oh almost got shot
kind of in charge of it well what are
your favorite weapons to use in this
game
um I am actually kind of boring in the
way that I like using the standard
loadout I'm kind of the same way I do
like that like like I can never get rid
of the assault rifle right I like that
one like laser thing that like he allows
you to handle multiple enemies it
reminds me of like Panzer surgery group
at Panzer Dragoon and uh what is it zone
of the enders that has a similar and a
laser attack
I don't like it most of buzzer because
it just reminds me without though oh
okay I like the heavy pistol oh yeah
that's the DLC weapon I think right that
was like one of the pre-order weapons
from back in the day oh I am I'm not I'm
not aware oh yeah yeah yes I played the
game after it already right right
that was a remember having to enter in
the code for that cuz I got that that's
a pre-order bonus yeah that that's a
good life one you can one-shot a lot of
people right
okay whoa oh whoa wow that guy's good
nothing tough get my number
people talk about zoning the endings in
the chat yeah never played it fantastic
well the second one is really good the
first one is a proof-of-concept okay all
right it's just it you know if anything
in has like it
I'd almost kind of put it in the same
pacings like not I mean it's not similar
to vanquish per se but in terms of like
its pace and stuff just the amount of
stuff that you're doing like you're just
right as you're wrecking robots for days
is a super fun exhilarating get that
same sensation
I guess so this week you miss one or if
like guys been going away and also I was
like a really anime like a robot like it
like storyline I'm always down with back
on the stuff yeah yeah gonna watch more
robot anime you forget me I got I was
really into Gundam when I was younger
huh they still going with us right they
are I mean it's like I mean it that that
remains it's like an OG anime series so
if they're always going to be making
Gundam but yeah I think there's a recent
one I was really good things a guy I'm
blooded iron blood orphans I think this
time yeah that's the one I've heard
people talk about you know it's actually
like there's like good in like a you
know like for the fans kind of thing and
there's like no no this is actually
really good right right like a
storytelling yeah I almost akin like one
thing a Gundam I kind of think of like
the anime version of like Power Rangers
not a sarange watch easier than Gundam
but is that like there's always gonna be
more of them you know with different
characters with a different storyline
like they're just gonna keep going right
totally totally I mean a lot of people
who were like originally like worked on
that like right from the start have
already kind of left to do their own
thing exactly because the fact that's
been so popular I mean that series has
had the grip constantly of whether or
not to like do we focus on the robots or
do we focus on the characters you know
yeah the constant struggle with I think
anyone has to deal with the robot anime
you know kind of mix up once he's in
focus on one yeah yeah right go on about
the history gun didn't free if you want
but I want to bore everyone look Ben's
talking about wanting to watch current
loggin again ooh I think I'm in but
that's definitely an anime that would
exist without stop like on them
totally totally i mean if you didn't I
mean that's reason that's one of the
things that makes like Gundam or Gurren
Lagann so enjoyable is because of the
fact that pokes fun it's a little logic
right I'm not just gonna but like I mean
a lot of its built on just like super
robots up which is like a sub-genre of
itself yeah I mean you really like
whether you like Gundam and I Gundam
definitely is like without Gundam there
wouldn't be a lot of anime that's true
that's for sure it's sort of a
progenitor a lot of ways yeah yeah and
an innovator like that genre itself it
one of the big things that did like a
robot anime in a more realistic scope
like it was very like overdramatize and
super like like almost you kind of could
take compared to kind of like shown in
logic in the way that these kind of
robot shows like function where it's
just like man that robot just got all
this crazy weapons and stuff but like
Gundam was more like putting the real
war angle like this is like real robots
people are being like these towns are
being destroyed by giant robots this
isn't good you know the human element of
that but yeah Gundam yeah someone says a
Gundam is the Final Fantasy of anime
that's an interesting angle yeah I kind
of see we're coming for that
long-running series different different
iterations of it all different and
inspires a lot of other people to kind
of like take that genre and do something
different with it you know late on
little boy these the guys want to take
care of quick in this challenge
this wave is they will overwhelm you
maybe by sometime so kakko says I don't
think I've watched nearly enough animate
to start talking about we watching stuff
that is a good point it was like so much
anime that it's like the idea of just
rewatching it is like man I have so much
more I neither what alright watch
actually interesting ly enough vanquish
is inspired by an old anime character
alright my name casshern which is a dude
like in a robot suit I don't know if he
was actually full robot but he had like
a dog robot and they like fought crime
together right and you were telling me
that apparently there was originally
going to be a dog yeah it was there was
and mostly because of that like
kashering connection that they're like
oh yeah
you know if we're gonna take that suit
idea they might as well might go the
whole way or the whole way to get the
dog and I guess they wanted to cut it
out what in cold oh it would've been
like mobile covered like it just like a
like get that dog out there that's
awesome I love that idea yeah yeah think
wish to decide anguish to God I think I
think wish to idea who knows oh boy
alright I should play get some of these
upgrades
boy how about this ben says i need to
watch more lupin because it's basically
the metal gear of anime and i love the
set that it took me this long to realize
i've never watched lupin coupon is one
of my favorites
well what metal gear that doesn't
surprise me
yeah it's it's actually it's interesting
like Lou ponds a great series to watch
if you were eerily into persona 5 by the
way right because the premise is so
incredibly similar it's like gentleman
thief concept yes and also is very
strong so main characters persona is
loop on yes yes exactly
named after the gentleman thief himself
I like that that a three had the whole
Greek mythology all the persona 4 based
on Greek gods and goddesses right and
then four was all Japanese mythology so
goss's you know is an ami and all that
stuff and then five they instead go with
fictional thieves you know we're like
romanticized you know so like Carmen
Sandiego which they just call Carmen but
it's like that is clearly that is
clearly Carmen Sandiego Lupin a Captain
Kidd who was a real person but you know
obviously a lot of like a lot of pirates
are very kind of like romanticized yet
exaggerated how much they did I yeah
yeah so I love I love that stuff and
like the Carmen Sandiego I don't know
what theme this was in but like I just
remember like maybe was the game show
that they had Ice Bear and be like where
in the world is calm sanity kidding well
they do the it's like it changes it's
like it's like a more robotic voice
saying yeah yeah interesting I think
that's the I think that's the show yeah
I might be the show I'm air being
exposed to current standing of San Diego
to some extent as a kid I just don't
remember what capacity when I played the
game PC games right remember I played
out some of the piece of games to the
kid I didn't watch much of a show right
and then they had um like a kind of
actual animated show oh yeah I remember
that interesting like the early
two-thousands when I watched a little
bit of that right through this uh gosh
fear yes we do read comments
dude Cooper did who's left
oh this thing with ninja says game show
here size from the game show okay cool
something real sounds better right yeah
watch this as a child we lad that's all
I know I just got a comment someone says
vanquish some pie and then just but your
heart question it's good I love it
oh hey boss fight oh wait no oh that's
not the Grenada one throw um okay this
could go bad hope that's not a boss
fight that's just one of those like
really yeah yeah big tough one crazy oh
uh not too often
yeah tech-noir says I should have
pre-ordered and got that extra five off
this looks really nice well I mean you
know even even twenty dollars is still
uh creating good good game pay attention
this cigarette please
yeah yeah you like that Oh terrible for
it get on that salvage salvage let's do
it
take this my love my anger and all of my
sorrow huh huh huh I can salvage this I
can make it work oh come on babe oh just
make it work oh yeah oh no just my time
here I got another cigarette pay
attention pay attention pay attention to
it
nope hey uh-oh I need okay
man this is getting dramatic Oh Oh me s
you help my buddies yeah get some of
that get an erection part excuse oh yeah
they give you him on the challenge they
don't give him on the challenging mode
do they know what this school yeah a
bunch of time see uh where's yet take
care uh is there unlimited ammo in this
game no there's not
yeah pick up ammo not just this really
cool mechanic though we're so they're
these little vacation when you kill
enemies who get these all like upgrade
boxes and when you pick it up it'll
upgrade whichever gun you happen to be
have equipped at the time which will do
things like increase the ammo increase
the rate of fire increase the damage but
in addition to that you also get an
upgrade every time you pick up a gun
that you already have full ammo for
which is like interesting food tactic
where it's like oh do I save picking up
that uh nice did it happen is there one
more guy is that it or do you say
picking up the gun to get the ammo later
or do you pick up the the gun not
getting the ammo but instead getting the
upgrade it's an eight idea and it keeps
with the pacing of the game where like
the game has upgrades dice what yeah
would have been cooler if I shot him
last but just got a Rando yeah so can be
at the game has upgrades but at the same
time you don't have to actually like go
into the menu yeah yeah which like keeps
going
flowing for sure I think it's about
gonna do it yeah it says vanquish my
heart racing man as it should
yes uh nope that's black all right well
I'm just gonna sit on this that's
supposed to be camera tell you got to
fix that later everybody so thank you
for tuning in this vanquish on the PC is
available today for 20 bucks you should
pick it up if you haven't played it
comes
one of my favorite games of all time
please yeah we uh give it some real big
fans here we've got more gameplay up on
YouTube in the site I put out a feature
talking about why this game so awesome
so go check that out
wait why are people talking about JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure in the chat I don't
know they were they I think we just from
the anime conversation oh yeah or just
spiraling out there I'm a big fan guys
big fan enjoy Robert E Oh Robert
yo speedwagon's my man he's my boy also
josuke is my favorite Jojo anyway
let's close this that's okay you can get
you Jojo in uh yeah so thanks for
watching we're going to have a couple
streams tomorrow me and Joey do a stream
every Friday morning at 11 so the J and
J stream look forward to that changing
and then at I believe to 2 o'clock we're
going to be doing a Tekken 7 livestream
that you're going to be on yeah watch me
get Rick watch him get wrecked at Tekken
that should be a lot of fun thanks for
tuning in guys and see you next time
take care